I would just like to not get into an
argument today okay well let's I think
our friends describe us as a loving
couple who bicker incessantly
she's more like social and outgoing but
I'm funny we like Christmas we look we
love Christmas that's yep during our
first holiday season together I'm pretty
sure I didn't give Dustin anything we're
here today to guess what is on each
other's holiday wishlist so I'm ready
first is the worst okay okay let's go
with bling I'm just gonna throw on these
earrings because you like she was like
I'm ten loves Funko pops
I love Funko pops I've got an Aragorn
Funko pop from Lord of the Rings in fact
I even proposed to her with a ring
design from Lord the Rings it's Gilad
reals ring I know that this is on the
list I have a group of friends we like
to play board games a lot we have a lot
of board games I can't keep up with what
they are but it's probably one of those
things that she was like oh okay and is
forgotten about but I feel like I've
heard this oh it's a bread shaped pillow
I am a connoisseur of nerd to body
changes he's not above it I feel like
she would also try and like put our cat
and a pizza outfit he thinks I have
enough class do it Chuck add all the
cute plant stuff I can just see her now
being like they're just these cute
little truck died I feel good about this
list
Wow a lot for the dog you picked so many
for the dog risky choice I ran across
that and was like whoa
you literally know me better than me it
seems I was not okay yeah I think Louie
is on there just blaze by the Millennium
Falcon the Millennium Falcon is not
something you just glaze by i glazed by
these looks most you my ears aren't
pierced oh they're candles but they're
cactuses that's cute yeah all the price
dropped 20% come on man oh cop that but
I want the newest GoPro so that's the
seven it's not the fun so close but so
far
boo that body jewelry is on my list aha
yes he's almost like bordering on a
little bit like creepy how well you were
able to pick out so much of my stuff
there's a million dumb things that I
want and she would know all of them she
only knows the surface hand there's so
much more she has yet to find out now I
know to share my wish list yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]